what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back again with another installment
of our beyond omega level series where
we discuss the strongest characters in
comics and as we get closer to the
release of doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness the rumors about
what characters we're going to see in
the movie are all ramping up especially
speculation as to who the villain of the
movie is going to be now there have been
a lot of theories but some people have
taken the fact that the trailer reveals
that doctor strange has been having
nightmares to basically be a clue that
dr strange's oldest nemesis nightmare
might show up in the movie so we're
going to discuss his origins and powers
in this video although it would be funny
if in that video he was like i have
nightmares and it's because of that guy
over there nightmare i'm going to go
fight him
uh so nightmare was created by stan lee
and steve ditko and first appeared in
strange tales number 110 in 1963 which
is actually also the same issue of
doctor strange's first appearance so
like i said earlier nightmare is
actually dr strange's oldest enemy now
nightmare was originally a servant of
the nearly omnipotent demonic entity
schumachorath who does appear in the
doctor strange trailer regardless of
what anybody says about it not being him
and i have done a biondo mega little
video on schumacherath if you guys want
to learn more about him i know they're
calling him gargantos it's a stupid name
gargantos did exist in marvel comics he
was a guy that appeared in one comic
book and died in that same appearance
the guy was kind of pointless but
regardless nightmare gets tired of
serving schuma gorath and strikes out on
his own by conquering the dream
dimension now from the dream dimension
nightmare casts terrifying dreams into
the minds of mortals and over time the
fear these nightmares caused become a
sort of sustenance for nightmare to the
point that he would actually cease to
exist if he was not able to consume it
now the question has to be asked here
what does a guy like nightmare do during
his downtime say for example nightmares
not instilling horrific dreams in the
minds of people who are sleeping across
the earth and he's just chilling well i
can tell you exactly what he's doing you
all know what time y'all know what time
it is don't act like you don't know
don't don't act like you don't know it's
skillshare time this video is sponsored
by skillshare now for those of you guys
who do not know what skillshare is
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
and creative classes for anyone who
loves learning so you can basically
invest in yourself and your personal
growth now for me as a person one of the
classes that i absolutely love it's
called youtube success build an
authentic channel that's worth the
follow by sorella moore it's a really
really cool class and the reason why i
chose this is because as you guys know
when it comes to my channel communist
explain i let my personality run free i
let my personality do its thing which
usually leads to me rambling for you
know a little while about unnecessary
things but i do love doing that right i
love just injecting my personality into
the channel and that's one of the things
that sorel talks about over the course
of her class that she basically talks
about this idea of having you use your
youtube channel to showcase your
authentic personality and believe me
it's very important to do that so for
those of you out there who want to
improve yourself to take the next step
to make 2022 the year that you become
the best version of yourself and you
want to take various classes to make
that happen then the first 1000 of you
the first 1 000 of my subscribers to
click the link in the description will
get a one month free trial of skillshare
so you can start exploring your
creativity today
but back into our video when we first
see nightmare a man suffering from
insomnia goes to doctor strange for help
but we learned that the reason for his
trouble sleeping is that he feels guilty
for basically committing a murder now
later we see nightmare trapping several
people in the dream dimension doctor
strange is basically able to rescue them
by going to sleep and entering the dream
realm but because he forgot to protect
himself with a spell prior to falling
asleep nightmare traps him in the dream
dimension but of course strange is able
to escape because that's just how comics
worked especially in the silver age when
villains were routinely introduced and
defeated in the same issue but nightmare
would become a very frequent foe of
doctor strange and really next to
dormammu who we've already seen in the
mcu he's probably dr strange's biggest
nemesis now he's also one of doctor
strange's most powerful enemies and is
really nearly omnipotent and omniscient
so nightmare's primary ability as his
name suggests is to allow him to draw
power from the minds of sleeping humans
which as we stated earlier he basically
needs to survive it has been revealed
that if nightmare did not exist humans
would collectively lose their minds like
literally they would all go crazy if it
were not for nightmare
this possibility represents a big enough
threat that doctor strange and nightmare
were actually willing to team up to make
sure that didn't happen now nightmare is
also a member of a team of extremely
powerful entities known as the fearlords
along with despair knox and kolaku some
guy whose name i've never been able to
pronounce in 25 years of course there's
also the lurking unknown and then
there's straw man who's actually the
most horrifying out of all of them
although later nightmare would
ultimately betray the team now the
leader of the fear lords is an entity
known as the dweller in darkness who
nightmare describes as basically being
his uncle now the dweller in darkness
has also been adapted to the mcu in the
shang chi movie and so that's another
clue that may hint that we'll actually
see nightmares showing up in the mcu
although the version that we see in the
shang chi movie doesn't really resemble
the comic's version of the dwelling
darkness all that closely but as is the
case with many of the characters that we
cover in the series it's hard to come up
with a definitive list of nightmare's
powers because he's nearly omnipotent
especially in his own realm instead
we'll go over some of the most
impressive feats to give you an idea of
how powerful this guy is so on one
occasion during the time that brother
voodoo had become sorcerer supreme
nightmare was able to turn almost all
matter in the universe to anti-matter
and basically forms the entire universe
so that it's nearly identical to the
dream dimension nightmare ultimately
proved too powerful for the sorcerer
supreme to handle and jericho drum had
to enlist the help of doctor doom to
undo what nightmare had done so this
feat is extremely impressive because it
suggests that nightmare is capable of
both matter manipulation and reality
warping which basically means he could
do anything he wants to do another feat
that shows off nightmare's power occurs
during steve inglehart's character
defining run on doctor strange and issue
number 13 from 1976. and in this issue
the cosmic abstract known as eternity
had basically vanished doctor strange
adventures to the dream dimension to
seek answers from nightmare who'd been
seen in a dream of baron mordo's a few
issues earlier now once he gets there
doctor strange basically finds that
nightmare had actually managed to
capture eternity and plunge him into an
eternal state of sleep now once strange
freeze eternity the abstract explains
that because one-third of the world's
population is asleep at any given time
nightmare was able to draw on their
power and over time just became
ridiculously powerful now nightmare then
infiltrates eternity's dreams and
attacks him from within to subject him
to whatever nightmare he chooses in
doing so nightmare was actually able to
manipulate eternity's dreams to affect
the world this is because eternity is a
cosmic abstract that represents
everything in existence in the universe
so his dreams quite literally become
reality and this is probably nightmare's
second greatest feat because eternity is
an extremely powerful entity so the fact
that nightmare could effectively attack
him indicates an insane level of power
furthermore if doctor strange had not
been successful in waking eternity from
his slumber nightmare could have caused
the entire universe to just stop
existing now in a truly bizarre story by
paul cornell called fantastic four true
story we saw another absurd display of
nightmare's powers as he's able to use
his ability to invade the human
subconscious to infiltrate the world of
fictional stories which reside in the
minds of humans now nightmare's effect
on the realm of fiction is felt by susan
storm who basically feels imagination
and creativity disappearing from the
world ultimately leaving her in a state
of depression now she starts to realize
as she goes to read to her daughter
valeria that both she and her daughter
are afraid to read so to understand why
people are afraid of fiction the
fantastic four build a machine they call
jasper to travel to the realm of fiction
where they find that nightmare is
building an army to overtake the
entirety of fiction now while this is
really strange at least even just for a
comic book story the fact that nightmare
could corrupt an entire universe that
exists beyond the confines of the marvel
universe and is vast enough to encompass
all of fiction shows us nightmare's
ability to invade the minds of others is
insanely strong and can be used to alter
reality now nightmare was also able to
physically influence all magic users on
earth including all the ghost riders
scarlet witch magic dracula and even
doctor strange and like many of the
demonic entities in the marvel universe
he is even more powerful in his own
realm where he's proven to be more
powerful than hercules ajax from the
eternals amatsu mikabashi who a lot of
you guys know as the chaos king and an
elder god named a tomb nightmare has
also been able to create his own plane
of existence and was able to gain the
upper hand while battling both all
father thor and loki at the same time
and most recently and i consider this to
probably be just the greatest most
insane thing that nightmares ever pulled
off in the 2020 anthology series that
was simply titled marvel nightmare is
able to take control of the earth and
turn it into a copy of his dream
dimension and then by doing so and
effectively feeding on the power of
everyone who's sleeping he's able to
overpower and kill all the cosmic
entities across the cosmos the
celestials eternity infinity galactus
the whole nine yards and then overpower
the living tribunal that at one point in
time nightmare was basically equal in
power to god now obviously this is not
an exhaustive list of all of nightmare's
feats but i think you get a good idea of
how powerful this guy is and i'm curious
to know if you guys think he'll actually
show up in the new doctor strange movie
or not but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this to an end thank
you all for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace